[Música]
bueno
voy a hablar de la desintermediación
pero voy a empezar al revés
los sistemas intermedia 2 son sistemas
que la sociedad ha usado durante mucho
tiempo
pues para resolver objetivos comunes
esta manera la ex se junta la gente o
las empresas resuelven una crisis con
tal de crecer y trascender hoy casi
todos los procesos
y sistemas que conocemos están
intermediados por ejemplo les va a poner
dos ejemplos uno es el comercio
minorista no es el retail tú tienes por
un lado productores de bienes y
servicios y consumidores y el
intermediario es un supermercado
es donde se juntan todas las partes y
hace la transacción de hecho hasta hace
poco era impensable
pues que este sistema existiera siendo
un intermediario como el supermercado
otro otro sistema de ese estilo es este
el monetario
la solidez de un sistema monetario está
dada por la confianza que tienen todos
los individuos que juegan en ese sistema
porque hay un jugador central pues que
resguarda y avala el valor de la moneda
tú tienes tu billete de 50 pesos y sabes
que si vas a ir a la tienda o el banco
tiene un valor y te van a y vas a
transaccionar
qué está pasando con la tecnología y ese
tipo de sistemas intermediarios
lo que estamos viendo es que dado
ciertos avances de tecnología y mucha
conectividad de acceso a información
algunos de esos intermediarios están
dejando de tener el valor o la
relevancia entonces podemos pensar en
sistemas de es intermedia 2 digamos
donde siguen pasando las transacciones o
siguen dándose las las ideas pero ya sin
el intermediario y eso lo que detona al
final del día es una eficiencia que lo
que hace es que para los que están
jugando en ese en ese ecosistema pues
haya más valor para las dos partes no
digamos ese pedazo del pastel que se ha
dado el intermediario o ya no se lo
lleva y se va hacia las dos partes
ejemplos de eso por ejemplo y volviendo
los dos primeros que les llamas aún hoy
nos está demostrando que no necesitas
tener una tienda para hacer retail
o por ejemplo algo que está muy de moda
horita el das bitcoins y las cripto
monedas también es una prueba de que el
sistema no necesita estar centralizado
para que pueda funcionar ahora todo eso
como que lo quiero para aterrizar a
ejemplos más puntuales y aplicados a
méxico entonces escoger dos sistemas que
creo yo que es muy claro que está
pasando estás desintermediación
el primero y no es de negocio es social
es la democracia
digo si nos digamos es un sistema muy
antiguo que viene de grecia
y la piedra angular detrás de sistemas
que todas las partes tienen tienen una
parte proporcional de poder y digamos la
voluntad de todas las partes es lo que
rige y entonces se crea toda una serie
de intermediarios como son los partidos
políticos como son después por ejemplo
en este caso el ine
que están hechos para que confluyan
nuestras voluntades y se logre el
objetivo de ese sistema
preparemos life
no se alcanza a ver el chiste de esto es
cuando un sistema está intermediado y
tiene poca tecnología tiende a ser muy
caro entonces ahí tenemos tres barras la
primera es el presupuesto que tiene el
ine para el año que entra y lo separé de
los 25 mil millones que son digamos la
parte azul es el gasto operativo y la
parte naranja es el gasto extraordinario
porque le tiene que asignar los partidos
para las elecciones puso otras dos
barras
entonces por ejemplo lo que lo que tiene
asignado el fonden para el 2018 que es
el fondo de desastres naturales y el
presupuesto del conacyt ahora por qué es
relevante este tema de la
desintermediación quizá
tú me dirías pues es bien importante que
el ine es una institución sólida y tal y
tal
digamos que es debatible que está
cumpliendo con su objetivo sin embargo
está llevando un pedazo del pastel y no
sabría si de esta manera más eficiente
de final presupuesto por el chiste es
que con tecnología y eficiencias
podríamos lograr los que el ine no
fueron una partida tan cara y esos
ahorros se podrán ir a partidas tus
hijos más inmediatas como como el fonden
que en caso de desastres naturales
presión importante o temas más
estratégicos como el conacyt que es una
apuesta que daríamos a tener a todos
como sociedad pues para que el país
prospere en el largo plazo el otro el
otro sistema que que decidí para esta
plática meter es el bancario
la banca desde que se inventó la banca
se trata de tener depósitos y prestar
dinero o salvaguardar los depósitos de
la gente y presta el dinero per se el
banco así que esa operación sea más cara
el juega en medio de los que prestan y
de los que piden prestado
entonces hoy otra vez con avances
tecnológicos digamos que podemos pensar
en que ya no haya un intermedio en esta
transacción que el que quiera prestar o
invertir dinero vaya directo con el que
necesita dinero y el banco no juegue
nada en medio como funciona hoy en el
modelo tradicional tú vas pones tus
ahorros en el banco
ellos te pagan una tasa si bien te va a
pagar una tasa
y después se fuerte and se vuelve a ni
prestan a tasas diferentes tarjetas de
crédito que hay todo el consumo
hipotecario tal con la tecnología han
salido modelos nuevos de negocios de
peer to peer landing no tú tienes otra
vez por ejemplo tú que tienes tus
ahorros en el banco y gente que necesita
dinero para sus actividades no para
financiar un negocio este papá de
colegiatura etcétera lo que sea
puedes poner en contacto a estas
personas vía canales masivos de
comunicación por ejemplo y hacerlo de
manera mucho más eficiente y sin fish
entonces el mismo pastel tú se reparte
entre menos personas
eso sí no se ve bien pero lo que traté
de hacer allí fue comparar las
estructuras de costos de un banco
tradicional y una plataforma de este
estilo de peer to peer de crowdfunding
no es que el otro modelo
digamos la parte de la
desde mi derecha
es cada línea de costos la sucursal es
los empleados en los sistemas el costo
regulatorio etcétera etcétera de un
banco y llega más o menos tampoco se ve
como a 700 700 que lo que hicimos fue
dividir esos costos entre el balance de
lo que tiene prestado el banco total y
lo agarramos una plataforma digital que
hace préstamos hicimos ese mismo
ejercicio todo lo que tiene prestados a
plataforma entre los mismos costos si se
fijan o bueno en la corte explicó pues
el banco tiene sucursales la plataforma
no
el banco tiene fondeo de un banco
central con un costo de capital la
plataforma realmente lo que hace es
conectar inversionistas estos tampoco y
los demás costos pues son inherentes a
cada negocio que que te arroja al final
eso tus que a lo mejor una plataforma
puede tener hasta 50 por ciento de
ventaja en costos pero eso es un baño y
eso al fin del día porque es importante
porque puede ofrecerle a la gente en
general más y mejores créditos más y
mejores opciones de inversión
en mexico en este caso ya tenemos casos
particulares de que está pasando esto
pero pero lo más impresionante de esto
todavía no está pasando en méxico en
méxico estamos en digamos en un proceso
de regular estos estas nuevas formas de
financiar las cosas pero si les hablara
de eeuu
tengo 33 así muy puntuales que son tres
plataformas online que hoy soy líderes
en su segmento de crédito entonces
tendría que el número uno en eeuu de
créditos personales se llama del end in
global
el número 1 de créditos estudiantiles se
llama south high y el número 1 de
créditos para pymes se llama one deck
ninguno de esos es un banco todas son
páginas de internet que están conectando
inversionistas con gente que necesita
crédito
es bien poderosa esa idea y un poco a lo
que voy con todo esto es que si se fijan
cuando des intermedias un sistema lo que
pasa que estás empoderando al individuo
entonces un poco a la luz de sus ideas
lo que a mí me gustaría que
reflexionaran ustedes
estamos en una en una época bien
interesante donde tenemos más
información que nunca estamos empezando
empoderarnos más que nunca y creo que
es llama de cada quien pero pero es
momento como de pensar cómo podemos
desde nuestro individuo
asociarnos con nuestros procesos
colectivos con empoderados que vamos a
estar para generar cambios positivos en
nuestro entorno gracias
[Aplausos]